hey how's going bros my name is fanny
pack let's keep playing until dawn that
[ __ ] in her bags I hate her
so I read a few rube bros comments and
someone said that you can practically
make everyone not die at some weird
sentence let's look at this totem see
what happens oh thanks totem appreciate
it Jesus but I want her to die so and
respect is king
I love it I would [ __ ] love this game
it's awesome let's keep going yeah I
know no bodies no Joseph I wish I was
where the wind was blowing they've had a
bang okay I'm gonna be pissed
am i wearing sweat pants come on oooh
x2x am i right ladies maybe you should
shell let's start over let's start over
I think we should start the weekend over
right now clean slate
oh no arguing no Mike I'm Jess
you and me enjoy ourselves and all this
nature you know this make straight I can
get with that I can get with that I can
get with that what does that mean what
are you on about my don't trust this
game there's jump scares around every
corner that interests it one bit
Oh what did I say
since when the lights turn on like that
since when skinny you know you knowing
that horror movies are like that doesn't
make sense why would that happen I feel
like there's gonna be a lot of that in
this but it's cool them that's the point
in the game flirt [ __ ] yes give me
somewhere private thought we were
looking for a bag but whatever what do I
know
everyone is so Horning this game our
kids our kids always like this seriously
a lack of humping in this game though
yeah thanks for helping me find my bag I
know I can be a little high-maintenance
that far why is she talking like that
why is she talking like she has a potato
in there but thanks for making me no
problem babe it's no problem but you got
to remember there's more to this guy
than just being a lean mean luggage of
lifting machine am i right ladies gonna
back that up all day that looks so real
what that [ __ ] does that mean oh my god
no that was that was that was mentally
challenged
he's wearing a mask and [ __ ] I don't
like it I don't like it one bit
don't psychoanalysis me game it's better
not be a goddamn clown or a spider or
some gory all right where's the sweet
guy where you need him
I think we'd spend this much time
outside not sure what what is going on
Burris
I'm seriously curious I'm gonna go I
already started clearing this all for us
come on
that's a the bench is a great spot it's
a very comfortable position all right
I'm sure you'll like [ __ ] you man this
snow is really making that noise hey
buddy how you doing
we need them now brilliant just
brilliant absolutely Magnifico all right
girl stop smelling your fingers all
right what now
you're not gonna talk to me am I making
a decision here
creepy or not creepy let's go to creepy
[ __ ] it let's check the totem out see
what's gonna happen
she just going to wait there for me what
there - put your hand in it
[Music]
Emily somethings remain stupid you guys
need to stop pranking now that was not
an animal that was not on the and in my
line let's go come on come on let's go
to the bench what what bench
now what Oh drop down what sweatpants
[ __ ] it's the muscles I'm a man
oh she can teleport now that's that's
pretty cool I wish I could teleport just
to freak people out you know I can
scream at one location and then just be
another yep or because I'm really lazy
and I don't like to walk that'd be
helpful too Oh what is this
what what the hell
that was not there before so note
welcome oh hell no that's when you know
where you get the [ __ ] out that's when
you know you get Davis Josh I don't like
this oh you're dead there dad's going on
they're dead kind of don't give a [ __ ]
about my panties anymore I kind of just
want to split best game dialogue ever
ten out of ten oh nice you brought me a
gift thank you so much Peter Stormare
right how are you doing today
what happened to your place you used to
be so nice Peter come on
what's up talk to me I would like to
understand your feelings toward people
of fear isolation okay tell me um I
don't think so no I'm happy alone how do
I feel about them what does that mean
exactly
I feel I feel sad for them of course I
mean um I wouldn't say pity but I would
probably say like I mean yeah yes is it
not did I not do that sorry I didn't
know it don't get in my brain I don't
like it
what are you doing such a great actor
what is he doing no your feelings toward
other people great ok I'm up for it
would you respect yourself alright maybe
you both will learn something here today
a big deal um oh that's a good question
oh that's a really hard question I would
honestly say loyalty so you would tell a
lie in order to be loyal to a friend
okay
and what about loyalty versus charity I
would value charity it's so hard why is
he giving and caring person thank you
thank you yeah I'd like to see myself as
such I'm afraid rather time we'll talk
again soon these are so weird
creep me the [ __ ] out
[Music]
what is that anchor doing there why
would you why would you keep an act
previously on until until on unturned
[ __ ] me it was just yeah it was just a
prank
do we need to see this I guess we do
today is the one-year anniversary of the
national tragedies of Hannah and that's
what really hurt Ole Miss I know it
would mean so much freaks me out we're
all still here together don't like him
butterfly effect excuse me did you say
something oh did you not hear me with
your sluttiness stop it Mike why don't
you check out the guest cabin when I
told you about yeah it reminds me a
little bit about siren blood pours did
you brush my play back that was made
like a TV show when I was a hurricane I
really liked siren blares I don't know a
lot of people hate that game because
they the controls are just hard of all
preconceptions drop all inhibitions and
generally give yourself over entirely to
the will we're doing this your every
desire the whims of the spirit master
which it doesn't say that and all
present will remove their garments at my
sole descriptors come on this is serious
would you brothers do this that's right
yes please okay
let's see what happens Ashley since a
recent convert Ashley looks so weird she
looks like such a cat lady okay let's be
serious okay anyone there will you
reveal yourself to us totally 100% I
didn't do anything good
H what's the spelling hold on how's this
happening are you moving it I swear it's
just moving help how are we supposed to
help I don't know what does it mean we
need to know who it is if we're supposed
to help them it's another prank let me
guess who are you oh my god oh here goes
okay sister sister oh and that's kind of
shut up ask you who's sister Josh it's
it's gotta be yeah okay well which
sister is it then Ashley asked who it is
really who are we speaking to Hanna
is that you
what that's [ __ ] Josh are you sure
because we can stop no dude it's cool I
want to hear what it says I don't know
where to start
it's her if this is actually Hannah I
mean we can find out what happened that
night
that makes sense Josh let me think
where is this going Hannah we miss you
and we want to know what happened to you
can you tell us what happened her nose
is so annoying
B beat bet are better ask him what
happened it's the only way to go ask the
mash okay
who killed you Hannah who was it oh I
party kind of sucks be library maybe
there's something library are oh oh
proof there's there's proof holy [ __ ]
Chris this is real Josh I don't know
what's going on listen no I don't know
if you think messing with me is somehow
going to help me deal with my grief or
whatever but not cool George know you
wanted to use the spirit for a calm down
it's it's not as nice right now
full of it oh man he just wanted to have
fun with his friends okay let's just
give him some time I don't blame him
that was crazy the pointer flew right
off the table if you're faking it I
wasn't faking anything I think we should
do what it says we should look in the
library okay
I just figure out the game he's the
killer isn't he to revenge his sister
cause he's the only one who didn't
partake in that night
and he lost both his sisters so he has
to motive right although it doesn't
explain who was out in the woods
but that would certainly explain why he
would get them here again and he seemed
really persistent on it don't you agree
I hope there's more to it I'm sure there
is but that's my theory for now I just
like to keep you both updated on my
thoughts now let's save our girls so we
can finally bang Jesus cried she's
screaming for help and you're like this
not funny
buddy but here why do you just
friendzone her
whoa what the hell is that the blue
anime what is that what is that what is
what was it
don't be so casual what do you say the
[ __ ] is something's breathing I don't
like this I'm not a fan of this no fun
at door of that at all
all right where is she who's breathing
are you in the tree
[Music]
you mean your booty never really know
someone until you okay Michael is my
favorite character now fine you win
now give me that border it's not a
contest but I do win every time oh my
god I want a functionary say babe
predators
see where it gets you
I hate you you ruin my laughs what's up
in the trees
what's up in the trees there's something
in the trees where we go into the lodge
anyway longest [ __ ] walk on my laughs
my laughs Bros my laughs and Michael I'm
going backwards aren't I I'm such an
idiot
my bad I don't know you could actually
do that so that's cool I guess do we
cross a bridge recently there's a trail
here I guess we'll see I know this as
far as remaining and then we can walk
here
worst-case scenario we find something
cool that bridge looks pretty cool where
are we going I know nobody's no one this
doesn't feel right this doesn't bode
well with me - we don't say and shred
and I know okay great this is a session
awkward angle - walking I wish I could
talk to the characters I think that
would add a little bit of immersion
since you're always - and - let's look
at our character traits
what do we get we add romance I wonder
how that affects the story that's pretty
cool I like how they're open with it
because a lot of times you just have to
guess it but I could what did that do
are we officially walking in circles
because I think yes I think yes I think
yes that's definitely what we're doing
is that our foot trace okay well I'm
sure we just missed a collectible and
walked in circles great
welcome to the food of high experience
are you enjoying it you are oh thank you
nice surnames I just want to snuggle
your face I'll hear this oh my god how
can I miss that I'm sorry all right
I know the bridge has had we all make
mistakes in life and not yeah it's
pretty how long I want to happen to the
bath girl how long is she gonna be in
that bat though she made the best
there's gonna be a horror thing in the
bath I'm sure was that a driller that
was a drill they haven't squirrel
drillers those are my favorite kind of
drills Oh what was that
they never answer when you're saved like
that bro you should know this oh it's
too much wildlife minute better hope it
out no that thing almost killed us
nothing else was ever saying he didn't
miss a anything fantastic hahaha Jame
yeah is she joking she's joking right
we walked this far for this okay they're
joking okay I wasn't sure
sarcasm how does it work this is the old
mask of some sort show a scare back
scary tits off
merci
Oh
[Music]
better get not heard about is fair play
my good lady I just scared you I didn't
so Hugh yeah that's dangerous everything
in my power
not underestimate my culinary jobs she
got over that fast seriously like a
frozen lake I'm not a frozen but it's
obviously minus degrees and you're wet
you could get seriously damaged so I am
yam a Brita bunch of jerk a big big ol
jerkface hashtag relatable that boat at
all right we better get you out of those
clothes Hannah all right all right all
right all right
that was Hershey pardon but I bet pepper
dip that better better pop up a dev Babu
a better pepper pepper that babbling but
whatever pepper bable bable bable bable
bable above up above booyah but about
gonna get that vote nope that's the
squirrel squirrel no big deal don't
worry it's a squirrel how's everyone
doing look at that's a squirrel squirrel
did that
that's awful there what would you do if
you saw a deer like that or an elk
like do you end this suffering I would
try and kill it but I don't know how I'm
gonna make this quick for you okay man I
this this gives me serious anxiety
because I remember when I used to fish I
could never properly kill the fish and
they would just make it worse shake it
get me fast we got to be fast we got to
be fast
what come on come on man we get it okay
yeah yes [ __ ] yeah first time event
suck on it
[Applause]
I'll tell obviously I gotta get laid
this is well we welcome milady
[Music]
hundred percent headed for sex not a
percent yeah totally beer don't worry
about it I'm pretty sure bears don't
know how to open cabin doors I've seen
them open car doors what we're on
YouTube that's amazing well yeah that's
right Jess idiot I would sit lock it
just to be safe okay I'm almost feeling
relaxed almost dammit come on come on
please please I need I need this this is
not the cozy Shelly I was promised Mike
well there is a fireplace fire Michael I
am a lady and a lady needs a proper
romantic setting Tammy make it so hard
oh maybe you would like to cuddle up
with her man buy a nice cozy fire bathed
in atmospheric mood lighting you know
good funny toasty what's rubbing up
against each other
nice fire and mood lighting yes my
ladies ladies it's so hard it's so hard
okay
all right I got this
please work please for the love of God
work please there we go we're done all
right good to go
please be fire please be fire into it
one two right just need a match just
need a bad look all right well why do we
do that
we got something over here please should
we read this let's open it all right
sorry sorry my bad my bad milady
I'll just show it
they like me now why do what was that
she'll never understand what we have
together I like this guy it's kind of
cool and he's about to get some do you
have matches
what'd she miss Mike what what is with
the girls in losing shame Ms it drops
out the side I can't lose my phone my
parents will kill me
you can always get a new one that's like
my fourth one this year okay okay damn
it
[ __ ] [ __ ] blocked by a phone fine I
just wish you hadn't gotten me
completely soaking wet trying to steer
oh my god did that [ __ ] sorry Jess
probably fell out in the water it
doesn't even work anymore anyway so
whatever I'll make it up to you I
promise
Oh goddammit we [ __ ] up now we find it
[ __ ]
lookee lookee who's gonna fire up some
nookie you've been dying use that line
since we got here haven't you
yep pretty much come on please for the
love of God we have one chance one
chance do not [ __ ] this up man one very
nice Bravo all right I think well I I
wish we had some booths well if I'd have
known that ahead of time I don't know
I'm not feeling it yet
maybe we just know where we got this
don't worry jump into it you know like
jumping into a swimming pool but maybe
we should start with a little you know
see where it goes from there
seriously did you think that would work
always has before
how is it different from [ __ ] out the
shutters what about them um close them
please it's just the one out there I
feel like someone's watching us
I don't like it it's fine I really don't
like it oh my god please please don't
cock-block me mr. murder I need this I
worked hard for this god damn it I
wasn't really [ __ ] on for this just
give me something at least I'll take
anything at this point I am kind of
desperate please shutters are shut
I'm sorry no no I'm sorry I think I'm a
little freaked out and it's hard for me
to like keep this up and look I act all
super confident and like a total sexy
babe and everything but underneath I
gotta be honest I'm really kind of
insecure was that the confession
it's reassure that she's super hot I
know how to play this game you have no
idea but you know call it a front he's
good he's real good
what happened they're continuing any
error blanket in it blanket blanket all
right I gotta be so so pissed if this
does not go my way why am I looking at
this girl
don't care blanket you're not a blanket
girl all right if you're not a blanket
right now you're wasting my goddamn
tannin where where this is a blanket
this is perfectly fine this blanket
what is this you're not a blanket yeah
hello all right maybe we should have a
little look around cami oh they don't
have blankets where is it Oh perfect
Charcot [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] how the
[ __ ] do you mess tops in there Mike
how the [ __ ] do you mess up doing that
that's a blanket bro that's a blanket
it's a shower curtain what do you know
about blankets come on don't even talk
to me unless you knew what [ __ ]
blanket sister but like it blanket like
a black a black a black a black a black
up like a black a black a black a black
a black blood god [ __ ] yeah
come here blanket no you do not not
right now
thank you yes no no no no no no no I'm
gonna bring the gun
why not seriously I would totally bring
the gun and my and my boxers and she is
wearing all her clothes bullcrap
I can't bring the gun come on man
who did this
nice phone
it's your phone what how is it my phone
I don't know damn it hey goddamnit
those goddamn [ __ ] probably boulders
out here to [ __ ] with us and just so
we're getting down to business
she wanted the D it's just as much as
idea I mean that's underwear don't
Hey Ya bricks
that means you
[Music]
all right no no no no no no god damn it
god [ __ ] metalbenders piss this is an
outrage gonna end that episode that may
break and then break at dammit
they've likely enjoyed and if you made
it this far